And and I think the reason why people like Kyle were upset is
that the words that they have used for many many years, things
like not racist, etc., all these words, have effectively lost
all their meaning. Like nobody really cares whenever they hear
these words anymore because you've used them so much that there's
been a diminishing return on it that people hear the word and
they just immediately stop paying attention to you. And the reason
why is because you've overused it. You've used it for
Let's hop into the first video. I'll do I'll do as Kyle Kolinsky
because Kyle has responded.
Okay, Kyle has responded and we don't even have to watch. Sorry,
not Kyle. Asmin Gold has responded. So, Kyle did a video reacting
to some Asmin Gold stuff and Asmin Gold as of yesterday has responded
in full.
All right, he's responded in full. This is going to be awesome.
It's an hour It's an hour long. The Kyle Kolinsky versus Asminold
feud is going to be great. I hope these two debate. That would
be fantastic. If you're a multi-polarity enjoyer, you probably
want China to get more powerful. I I don't understand how you're
a multiplayerity enjoyer in any sense if you if the only other
polls are like autocratic, but whatever. Whatever.
Asmin Gold wouldn't agree to a debate. Ah, you never know. It's
Kyle Kolinsky.
Kyle Kolinsky says some wild. Asmin Gold might think he's got
a shot.
It's
Okay, so we're going to check this out. Kyle watched one of Asmin's
videos, just said Asmin's totally insane. I believe it was the
one where Asmin Gold's complaining about how like Republicans
can't get any breaks, how they get just totally treated like
Democrats get like a pass on everything where he sort of inverted
reality and Kyle Klinsky started having an aneurysm. So, we're
going to watch Asmin Gold cover that video. Let's check it out.
>> This guy
This guy crashed out about I guess this is like a clip that I
did. I am apparently the dumbest person to him. One of the things
that's been driving me crazy more and more lately is uh when
you have people who have large
>> who don't know what the they're talking >> but
they're just desperate to start giving their political takes
and
>> Because um look, you do a massive disservice. You have
this giant audience of people who follow you and if you're out
there, >> the disservice is disagreeing.
>> Spreading false notions of politics. >> Um that's
unacceptable. That's unacceptable. The best example of this is
Joe Rogan who doesn't know his ass from his elbow, but uh he's
out there. He was at the inauguration. He gave Trump a softball
interview. Gave JD Vance a softball interview.
Uh hot >> didn't give you an interview. I can see why you're
mad. >> Stone massages every billionaire in the country
on his show regularly. But then he'll go on a show and so who
me, bro? I'm just like a centrist. I'm like I'm not right. I'm
not left. I'm sort of above the fray and stuff. Like it's >> He
tries to do this enlightened centrist bit. Meanwhile, he's like
>> I thought this is about me. Let's get to the part about
me. >> Slime, you're going to have to deal with me laughing
at Kyle Kolinsky. Okay? You think I don't love Kyle Kolinsky?
You know I love Kyle Kolinsky. I'm going to laugh at him sometimes.
He's a guy who is funny, but he is not polished. Okay? And that's
a part of his charm. He's going to say things and he's going
to get like jabs thrown back at him and he could be content even
when he's getting made fun of. Okay? He's funny. Hey, I'm going
to laugh >> on the Trump train quite literally. So, >> um
he's a great example of it. Another one is Asmin Gold. That's
my goal. He's been getting more and more political. Um and I
just I mean I hear this I just want to shove my nuts in a waffle
iron when I hear this >> cuz like what are you saying?
What are you saying? You you know you don't know what you're
talking about. You know you don't know what you're talking about.
But he does it anyway. So here he is giving his theory. >> Okay.
So here here all right. All right. Here we go. This is me talking.
All right. Let's find out
>> about how you know the Democrats they've been so radicalized
that the Republicans are the poor put upon Republicans. They're
just like reacting to what the insane Democrats are doing. I'M
NOT KIDDING. I'M NOT. That's his actual argument. Let's watch.
>> This is a uniquely I think it is a unique Democrat problem.
Now, when a Republican does something bad, here's the big difference,
right? It's not the >> Oh, boy. I'm going to have to move
my face, aren't I? Oh, no. I don't. We're >> We're in the
We're in the Asmin Gold. So, Asminold reacting to Kyle reacting
to Asmin Gold. Wait, me.
All me reacting to Asenold, reacting to Kyle, reacting to Asmin
Gold. Let's go. >> Republicans don't do anything bad. But
when a Republican does something bad, everybody generally says,
"Oh, okay. That's really bad." But the problem is that Democrats
look to try to, you know, like, "Oh, it's not that big of a deal.
It doesn't matter that much. Who cares?" >> Now, do you
understand why I said >> this made me want to shove my
nuts in a waffle iron? >> Great argument.
You know what that you I I never saw it this way whenever I said
it, but now that you say that you want to put your dick in a
waffle iron, I completely agree with you. I actually was wrong.
Yeah, I was totally wrong. Homie literally said, >> "Yes,
it's not an argument. It's a reaction."
Nobody Nobody pauses when Asminold makes his little face and
goes, "Look at this stupid face. Nice argument, bro. Just get
let him cook for two seconds, dude." When a Republican does something
bad, other Republicans could be like, "Yeah, that's bad." >> Yeah,
generally. I think true. I think it's more true than for Democrats.
I'm sure there's exceptions, but I think it's generally true.
Yeah. >> That might actually be the least true thing I've
ever heard in my life. That is somehow the most false thing I've
ever heard in >> Okay. So, so the argument is no. Got it.
>> entire life.
>> Asmin Gold, bro.
>> Great argument. >> Let me just tell Let's Let's
just go with Elon Musk. What did Elon do when so as keeps going
great argument I have future sight you know in this case because
we watched the Kyle video first so I know that Kyle's going to
start hammering out example after example after example and we'll
see what Asmin Gold says then cuz what he originally what he's
saying now is great argument great argument that means he's going
to engage right once Kyle actually starts making arguments when
he starts giving examples I'm sure he's going to actually lean
in and say some that that is meaningful
hopefully when he was running Doge you guys all know this. How
many times have I given you the list? >> All right. >> He
cut pediatric cancer research.
>> Not a single Republican came out. Not a single Republican
came out and criticized him for cutting child cancer research.
Has it ever occurred to you that maybe the research was done
in a way that was bad? Like every time that people say something
like, >> "Oh, this is uh Asmin Gold really does love Elon
Musk."
Dude,
when you when all you do is like play devil's advocate for somebody,
you are advocating for them. You can't consistently play devil's
advocate for somebody and then when people go, "Hey, you must
love that guy." You can't go, "No, I Why would you say that?
What if I ever said, "I'll say I don't even like Elon Musk."
It's like, why? You're literally defending him right now. And
then to defend him, you are coming up with hypotheticals that
you can't prove that you have no evidence of in order to defend
them. That's what that's stupid.
If you have to like that's what you do for your friends. That's
what you do for people you love. You come up with hypotheticals
and examples of how they might not be monstrous or they might
not be bad.
Why are you doing it for a random billionaire? Dude, what's going
on like this? The implication is that oh, they're curing cancer
or something like that. This is Yeah. And also on top of that,
yeah, just because you're doing research doesn't mean that it's
a good allocation of government money. What if the research that
you're doing is problematic? What if the research is not funded
properly? What if you're getting too much money? There are all
of these questions. It's like basically doing cancer research
is not an immediate and infinite get out of jail free card from
any degree of accountability and any amount of government oversight.
What a crazy thing to say.
Oh, but it's it's it's for cancer kids.
Okay. Great great emotional argument. We love that. This is the
exact reason people started on Adam friended over Trump. Yeah,
I know. I literally I don't know if you know this stall in a
sloth. I went and talked to Adam and I just said so you admit
you're basically just like creative writing to come up with reasons
to defend this guy. You can't just consistently do that over
and over and over again and then go don't say I like that guy.
I don't like that guy. It's like no you you do. You totally do
and that's okay. Just don't lie about
That's all you got to do, buddy. Just don't lie about it. Just
be honest. Yeah, you love that guy. >> It's optics. Yeah,
it's just optics. It's just the way that it sounds. Because the
idea of Oh my god, he's cutting grease. No, he's not saying he
knows that it was bad. Vigilance stream, he's saying hypothetically
it could have been bad. Hypothetically, there could have been
problems. Hypothetically, hypothetically, hypothetically,
uh, hypothetically, maybe this is wrong. Hypothetically, maybe
that's wrong. It's like, okay, but you don't know that.
You You don't know that. And I'm guessing that a ton of Asminold's
like entire thing here is just going to be consistently obiscating,
consistently like playing devil's advocate with no evidence for
any of the things he says, right? That is going to be a significant
portion of his defense of Elon Musk and
He's just going to say, well, you don't know that this is the
way it Okay, I So Kyle's mad that pediatric
research was
He is mad that in general the US government decided that pediatric
cancer research was not a priority. That is something he knows
happened. That is something he could be upset about. You you
have two options. You could say, well, I have to do more research
to see why it was cut to know what my opinion should be. Or or
you could say, hey, in general, I like or dislike that and then
I do more research to see if there's something that changes my
mind. Right? You could you could handle it that way. But in general,
you just agree or disagree with that. Hey, the US government
should be involved in this or not. And Asold is not even giving
his position. He's just going, "Well, maybe actually this was
like the perfect cut of money. Maybe they're actually like maybe
there's a ton of fraud there. Maybe those people were actually
just kids. Maybe they maybe instead of researching cancer effects,
they were actually researching how to grow cancers in in kids.
Do you think about that, Kyle? Kyle, did you think about that?
I didn't think so. I didn't think you thought about that. You
just decided to soy out like a liberal."
Good one, Kyle. Search for cancer kids. Oh, no.
That sounds bad.
By the way, there was one of those things was literally a cure
that worked. Oh, okay. So, we had a cure. Let me Let's get this
straight. Okay. Okay. Now, Kyle has stepped out of line. Kyle
stepped out of line now
cuz Aspen is going to say the obvious thing. If it's a cure that
works and like could be monetized, you're telling me capitalist
like pharmacy companies, pharmaceutical companies wouldn't have
done that? They would have just let that go. They don't give
a about making money anymore. to actually just go, "Yeah, you
know what? Never mind. I don't want to make any money." That
seems unlikely. We had a cure for cancer.
We almost had it, but Donald Trump and Elon Musk turned it off.
>> Okay, sure. I'm not kidding. It was a gene editing thing
that they used to stop leukemia. They tried it on somebody, it
worked. He cut the >> funding. Okay,
so it worked on one person,
which again I'm not even sure whether this is true. I I don't
have that. I don't have it in front of me. I don't remember this
happening at all, by the way. But like, okay, so we have one
person it happened on.
>> Leukemia is cancer. Yeah, it's blood. >> I don't
think this is crisper, is it?
These would be like um uh these would be like gene inhibitors,
right? They're like inhibitors that prevent you from producing
certain things. I think I think I think it's like but maybe that
is crisper. Maybe it's like something you make with crisper.
I don't think it's the same thing. >> Blood cancer. >> National
Weather Service which literally led to deaths. It led to deaths.
There was a a late warning that went out because he cut the National
Weather Service and uh you have these kids at a Christian sleepaway
camp who died. He cut.
Wasn't that proven false? I don't >> Shoot me a link. Oh,
so I Oh no. There's no way as a as pre-watched and then he got
all of his examples to argue back. Uh-oh.
Crisper's knockout gene inhibitors are knockdowns. Trust you.
I trust you in this case, but I actually I don't know enough
about that stuff to even know what that means necessarily.
Sorry, man. Sorry, man. I live in Texas.
Meteorologists say the National Weather Service did its job in
Texas. Doge cut hundreds of jobs at the NWS, but experts who
spoke to Wired says the agency accurately predicted the state's
weekend flood risk.
These are meteorologists.
If you don't know, that's a weather wizard. Dude, dude,
Asminold Asminold's going to like brutally tile here. This is
the thing. Everybody thinks Asminold's just a total when he speaks.
He is not. He's not
a total He's pretty calculated. He's pretty smooth. There's a
reason he rolls along all the time doing the same shtick all
the time, right? And he doesn't get got the same way a ton of
other people get
The one time he really [__] up was the Palestinian
like genocide thing. Oh, it's okay to genocide them. And he just
took that on the chin and walked away for a week and came back,
right? He just went, "Yeah, you know what? I totally [__]
up." He totally ate the loss. He held the L and he went, "You
know what? I [__] up. I'm going to be better." And
he came back and he didn't do anything to be better, but he said
he would. Okay, he took the L. He said, "I up." He walked away.
He's like, "I'll be better when I come back." And then he doubled
down in the same direction. But hey, he took the L temporarily
and
and that just makes people like kind of stop bringing it up.
I guess those are people that understand the weather.
Well, would you look at that?
Would you look at that? Sounds like some spec and and this is
the thing, right? You give a specific example and it falls apart.
>> Meals on wheels, right? >> He cut the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau, which is the anti-scam police. No
rep.
>> Good. They weren't doing their job.
They obviously had no idea what they were doing. The scams have
been through the roof.
So, yeah. Wow. Let let me let me get this. Wait, hold on. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Did I get what that was? Falls apart.
>> Hold on. Hold on. I got to listen to it >> There's
a consumer protection thing,
>> Wheels. He cut the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau,
which is the anti-cam police. No rep. >> Yes. Yes. So,
in response to crime being through the roof, would Asmin Gold
say, "Yeah, we should get rid of the cops. Defund the police
now because
defund the police because crime is through the roof." He's about
to say, "Oh, guys, they must not they suck at their job. Fire
them." Yeah, scams are through the roof. Oh, did it help when
you fired the people who prosecute that? Good. They weren't doing
their job.
They obviously had no idea what they were doing. That scams have
been through the roof.
So, yeah. Wow. Let let me let me get this straight. Okay. So,
there's a bureau of people that are supposed to stop scams
and you want to keep them on payroll?
Dude, there's no way he's doing this argument right now. Okay,
Kyle's going to respond. He Kyle's going to get Kyle's going
to lose his mind at this part, right? Yes.
Asmin Gold's a defunder. Asmin Gold is actually a defunder, guys.
Crime is up. Crime is a terrible thing and it's up everywhere.
Murder rate is up everywhere.
>> Defund the police.
>> They sucked. Republicans criticized any of these things
throughout. Yeah, >> HE FIRED 83,000 VETERANS. NOBODY CRITICIZED
IT. Oh no, you can't fire veterans anymore. Didn't you know that
we're not allowed? I thought he's just gonna go, "Oh my god,
they dude." Uh, at some point, I swear to God, it's going to
be like uh the in, you know, halfway through the third Trump
term. It's like Trump lined up and shot 400 journalists today
and he's GOING TO GO, "OH, SO THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T EXECUTE journalists
now, Kyle." Well, you saying the government can't execute a little
bit soy there, Kyle. The government can't just execute journalists,
Kyle. What are you talking about? That's not logical. Use your
logic, Kyle. Out to fire veterans. Another emotional appeal.
>> He fired 250,000 government workers overall. Nobody
>> good. It should have been moreized
it when he cut us a cutting off malaria medication from going
to people who need it. HIV. Uh, not you're in dress. Okay.
Not your dress. I don't even know how to say your name. He is
literally right though. Kyle names things like they are objectively
evil or something. those things like they are objectively object
objectively evil or something. Okay, he's not right. He's not
making an argument for whether Kyle is right or wrong. Kyle is
saying, "I like pediatric cancer research. I like the Consumer
Fraud Protection Bureau or whatever." Right? I like these things.
I think they do good work. And Asmin Gold is just going, "What?
I don't care." Well, I don't care what kind of work they Asmin
Gold is just playing devil's advocate with no knowledge. Right?
This isn't intelligent. He's not correct
at all. He is just poking holes. This is not actually like difficult
to do. I'm doing it now to Asminold, right? Well, I I think I'm
more trying to read both sides in a Warren Smith type fashion.
Okay. But it's not difficult to say this. I'm telling you it's
it's not saying something substantial. He's just going, "Oh,
so you're saying this is bad? Oh, do you know if like maybe maybe
they were just doing fraud? Maybe they just weren't doing their
jobs." And he just went with, "Oh, well, fraud's way up. Um I
yeah I guess fire all all the fraud police. None of this makes
any sense.
Uh most government programs are a net good for the money they
spend past midnight. Like sorry most I would say most like government
workers probably the thing is I don't know how you solve this.
I feel like the thing that can be most automated out of existence
is like the government bureaucracy. I feel like so much of government
bureaucracy is just people moving data from one place to another.
There's like no reason that that shouldn't be moving way faster
and you shouldn't be cutting like so many jobs.
But I would say people like police, a lot of like actual
I guess government utility things that provide like actual utility
like significant utility. Um cops,
what else? Like city maintenance, city clean up, you know, trash,
people who clean up trash and stuff like all of this. These are
things that provide a ton of utility for the money you spend.
There's no reason it ever gets rid of stuff like that. People
who police fraud, people who
uh like IRS agents, these people, huge net utility, right? Huge
net benefit to the country. Every time you add an IRS agent,
you are adding a positive boon to your taxes.
Like for every IRS agent you add, you gain tax uh taxable income
in the country. Let's see here.
Oh man, I agree that DOE hasn't made US kids competitive. Oh
my god, I had like a brain blast about this today, dude. People
are going to start there's probably people arguing this already
cuz no thought is unique, but like this is going to be a total
tangent, but I have to say it for a second. Um, are
if if H1Bs
are getting hired at like a massive
what is the utility of a massive of like a hugely expensive US
education? Is that not like rapidly dropping? Should universities
not be rapidly dropping their prices? If every like white collar,
you know, worker is going to get replaced by like an H1, sorry,
if if a ton of white collar workers in the states are getting
replaced by H-1B visas from universities that aren't even rated
in some cases, okay? They're basically, you know, printing certificates
for people,
right? Lots of these people come over with even H-1Bs and they're
not effective. Not the ones that go to like Google or something,
but the ones that go to smaller companies, okay? They're not
even like they're not really up to snuff.
And you Americans are paying out the ass for education
and there aren't even jobs that you get with that education right
now. Like like jobs are so hard to come by right now. Even less
I'm saying that like these people are coming with H-1Bs in a
lot of cases. They're coming from other places and they're competing
in the American market
and they don't have the American cost of education. America basically
has a massive anchor strapped to every American citizen because
of the cost of education. Like the education system of in America
is an anchor preventing every American from actually realizing
happiness in their lifetime
because what you need to do okay is go to Islamabad or Mumbai
and go to some university there and then come back, right? Like
that's the issue is there are all these regulations. You're supposed
to have all of these like certificates. You have to go through
this university. It's like a respected program. And then if they're
just going to hire somebody from India who spent like, you know,
the the equivalent of like $500 a semester on their education,
why? What the [__] is happening? Oh, I guess they
are $100,000 now. Kerki, I guess they are like 100K now. I'm
just saying that like at this point,
if if the marketplace is global,
how is the American education system not starting to compete
with the global marketplace in some way? like
like that is a a massive problem that somebody in government
needs to solve,
right? I'm not saying university is not important. I think education
is important. But the issue is is if you're in a different country,
your education is nowhere near as expensive.
And so you're saddling all these people with massive debt for
what? There is no advantage to having that education. Like that
advantage to having that education over getting that education
somewhere cheaper has disappeared.
So, I don't know. There's like the state schools. You can go
to state schools and stuff and and get a little bit cheaper education,
but somehow there's like there's got to be a way
to point out that people are coming over for jobs in America
and they don't have like an American education, like an American
debt they're coming with. There has to be some equalization there.
Like if the if the cost of doing business to enter the you know
the American workforce is a college degree aren't majority of
H-1Bs if they are then that argument disappears
but I would say it's not even H-1Bs necessarily at this point
Porter Beller I'd say for software for jobs that can be done
remotely you're competing in a global marketplace with people
who like don't have that same barrier it it feels like and it's
not even that it's like an injustice it feels like Americans
are taxi drivers and they have to pay for like a medallion to
do business and then they go to get a job and they realize that
somebody has just outsourced the job they would have wanted to
go for to India because in India it cost them you know 1/100th
the amount to get educated and start doing that own that that
job and you know somebody's contracting their services out and
you're basically considered equivalent to that person but you
need to charge like a 100 times more right it's regulating like
slowm moving regulations if you think of education as regulation
in a Hey, it's like you'd have to show me the real numbers. I
can't show you the real numbers. I can show you the real numbers
in terms of outsourcing even less. You'd have to show me the
real numbers. It's not even H-1Bs. It's outsourcing too, right?
How are you supposed to compete in a global market for as like
a software developer, let's say, with an education that's like
massively expensive? Like there's a barrier to entry and for
some reason America it just costs like infinitely more.
And how how in the world can you be competitive in that world?
How can you be competitive? I don't know. I was thinking about
it. I think there's something there. There's something to like
go with there. I think there's like a a complaint there, a a
thing that needs to happen, but I again I just I thought about
it this morning and I wanted to say it on stream so people could
tell me like what part is
if you guys are thinking about it too. If I get you guys thinking
about it, somebody will tell me like what's wrong, what's right
there.
It's not like I'm not complaining that it's an injustice or education
needs to be free. I'm saying that like in terms of if you're
looking for workingclass policy,
there's something there
somewhere. There's something about like, hey, we need to address
this like inequity that is now inverting
American labor dominance. There's there's like an argument to
be made there, but I don't know. Anyway, I'm going to continue
on with this video. My bad. I I wanted to get that idea all out
on stream though before uh before it slipped away from my mind
again.
>> Oh no.
That's right. It's America's. You don't need formal education
for software. You do not. I'm not saying you need formal education
for software. I'm saying there's like you do need a formal education
for accounting. Then there's the H-1B thing. It might be that
H-1Bs are all, you know, people with American degrees anyway.
And then for nonH1B for like outsourcing that, you know, you
don't outsource any job that requires any sort of certificate
anyway.
But then to get into those fields in America, to get hired in
those fields in America, it's like the common perception is that
you need this degree. I don't know there I don't know, man. Responsibility
to pay for people that have HIV and AIDS in
>> This is true, Madison, but unfortunately
companies aren't paying as if this is the case. This is the case
if you work at these companies. I know cuz I still go like for
lunches and stuff with people who are working in this industry.
And what do they complain about when I go out with them? How
the outsourcing teams that they have are worthless.
That's what they compl That's what every single one of them complains
about. Every single one of these outsourced teams is useless.
But that's at least my experience. I'm obviously not working
in those fields right now, but every time they they talk about
like their outsour outsourced employees, they're just like, "Yeah,
this is it's like such a headache."
>> That's right.
Oh yeah, people have been dying in droves. They have Is is he
specifying in America or not? No, he's not. It's because it's
not happening in America. He's right that USAD was funding the
uh lives of a number of people outside of America. This is absolutely
true and that's why a lot of people voted to get rid of it. It's
because you have people here that are dying from lack of medical
care. You have people here that don't have housing. And so why
is it that we are allocating money and resources to stopping
HIV and AIDS in countries that are not our own, but we're not
able to keep cows? You want to talk about veterans? Why are there
Why are there any homeless veterans? Where is the priority list
that a veteran ever gets outranked by a person in Africa? That's
not the place that I'd want to live in. I'll tell you that. That's
crazy to me. I think I think the idea of comparing them one to
one is like to house that homeless veteran you could probably
save like a thousand Africans I think is probably like the the
difference right like USA aid for like the amount it would cost
to house a homeless veteran you you save like a thousand Africans
I I'm sympathetic to Americans who say I still don't care even
on those even at those ratios
but but it's like do the actual do the actual comparison and
then and then advocate to actually you know clothe and feed feed
and house your homeless veterans. Don't say, "Hey, actually,
if if we wanted to use the money for that, why wouldn't we just
take care of the veterans?" And then never advocate for taking
care of the veterans. Okay? Actually, actually care about that.
Actually go advocate for it. Actually get mad when politicians
don't pass it. Well, Jtock, since you've been gone, Indian software
engineers have AI and have been doing pretty good. Maybe
you all use cursor now. Yeah, maybe. Could be. Criticize it.
>> Of course, because I agree with it. Yeah, I agree with
it. Good, good call. W your minds and that's just and that's
just Elon. I didn't even mention Trump. >> Which, by the
way, and also all of these examples here that he's given are
policy decisions and not actual violence. I was discussing things
like Charlie Kirk and Jay Jones in the clip. And so he's he's
misinterpreted what I've said. And he's even making an argument
that doesn't even make sense in the context of what I
So, not only did you get the argument wrong, but to the extent
that you're making your other argument,
um, that makes some sense.
I'm guessing you probably have like some heads of engineering
in North America, too,
to like put up vision and stuff. Basically, I find it's like
mostly the lowest level, like the the leaves of the trees,
like your lowest level software engineers are usually outsourced.
Yeah, that one's also wrong. Trump has been bombing random dinghy
fishing boats with innocent people in them. >> How do you
know that?
You really think? >> Cuz the president of one of those
countries said, "Hey, a citizen of my country was in that boat
and we're kind of pissed
and Trump refuses to ever prove again.
Just how do you know that? Wait, how do you know that? Can you
prove that? Can you Can you prove it? Can you prove it beyond
a shadow of a doubt? It's just going to be again obiscating just
playing devil's advocate, right?
Yes, exactly. This is in the other direction. He doesn't actually
know that it's true or not true. This is just like the first
point we went through, right? He has no idea. He's just going
to play devil's advocate. He's always going to play devil's advocate
in favor of the cuts for some reason. Like when you when you
always advocate in a specific direction, you're just giving away
the side you actually care about and want to advocate for, right?
You cannot play I I dude I've I've cracked I've cracked it on
this one. Okay. You cannot play devil's advocate for the same
devil every single day and then say I hate the devil. I hate
Satan. Okay, [__] Satan. No, you advocate for Satan
every day. You are you are actually Satan's advocate. Okay, the
devil's advocate. I can't think of like a better way to put it
cuz all these people will go it's like Tim P, right? He'll he
spent years sweeping for Trump and then he eventually comes out
and says, "Oh, Trump's a great president. and I love Trump. But
for the longest time, you go, "I'm not a Republican. I don't
like Trump. I'm not a Republican. I don't like Trump. I'm not
a Republican. I don't like Trump." >> What about the submarine?
Was that a fishing submarine, too? >> Wait, didn't they
Did they blow up the submarine? I thought they did a raid on
the submarine and made it surface and got everybody off of it.
Wait, did they blow up a submarine now? like uh I I have heard
that some of the
some of the drug cartel like the cartel warlord type people have
like Russian subs that they bought and they actually take drugs
with with subs. I've heard that. Right.
Heard it. You are where you sweep. Yes. >> Do you really
think that's another good one that they're blowing up? Really
think that that they're fishing boats?
>> No. Probably not all of them. I'm guessing most of them
are like actually trying to smuggle drugs.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, I'm thinking unless they blew up
a sub, like I'm all down. I'm down for them capturing those boats.
For them going and capturing those people and dumping the drugs
overboard. I'm down for that. It's just probably using drones
to kill them is is a little much, right? That's starting to get
into some really dystopian territory.
It's Oh, this is an innocent fishing submarine.
Don't you guys have those
with four motors on them? Yeah. And by the way, >> wait,
does he not understand that fishing boats would have like multiple
motors on them?
>> So, let me get this straight. So, the US government
can read a license plate with a satellite
from outer space, but you think that a Twitter post that said
that the people were innocent is more accurate than
Sure. And it nobody on the right has been criticizing it. It's
the president of
one of those countries, one of the Central American countries
said that that was his that those were his citizens on one of
the boats. Does Asmin Gold not know about that one?
Colombia. Yeah. The president of Columbia came out was like,
"Yeah, you just blew up my citizens. What the fuck?"
at all. Because because they agreed. >> Yeah. We should
remind Asmin Gold. Okay. You should you should just say the government
was correct in doing anything they did all of the time regardless
of what it was. Okay? You have to prove every single time you
want to do a conspiracy against the government. No, you have
to prove that beyond a shadow of a doubt. As Gold or else you
shouldn't say it or else you're dumb for saying it. Okay? Never
allege a conspiracy. Never allege that that you know something
seeming improper could be improper. Don't do it. Asmin Gold agree
with it because it's the right thing to do. It is. Absolutely.
Bull up the boats without even a question. How could you be against
that? I mean, these are people that are trying to bring drugs
to our country that are going to kill our people. If I saw somebody
running at my house with a bomb, I would want to them before
they got to my house. I wouldn't want to try to apprehend them,
arrest them, and try to put them through a whole process. No,
you just I think
Why Hold on. Huh? And I'm just spitballing here.
Why don't you just I would I think this is better, but everybody's
going to think this is monstrous, but this is where my brain
goes. Go to the boat, search the boat, and if you found like
a a smuggling level of drugs, something beyond just like personal
use, you find that they're trafficking drugs, just shoot them
and throw them overboard and then sink the boat.
But like, go and make sure they're actually smuggling drugs first,
right? I make sure you don't have false positives. Just go. And
then if you have a [__] a bunch of on a boat, just
shoot them and throw them
That's That's all. And by the way, then you could make sure that
there isn't like a kid in the hole,
right? Then you know exactly who your kid I don't know. That's
that's me. That's what I think. And I understand most people
are like, "But they should get a trial and all of this." Well,
it's international waters. You try You tried your luck in international
waters, buddy. Okay.
And he'd do the same thing. They've all been lying and pretending
these are narco terrorists and Trump. >> They're lying.
Okay. Where's the argument that they're >> It's killing
the right people and stuff. This insane. This is insane. >> It's
insane. Okay. Well, that's a good argument for why they're not
>> Yeah. No, I'm sure the fishing submarine
uh it was just a bunch of, you know, like poor innocent Venezuelans
who were just trying to get by and they only had enough money
to cobble together for one submarine. And you know what they
say, right? You got to fish where the fish are. And so they had
to go underwater to get the fish. >> True. You got to fish
where the fish are. Yeah. >> Even if they were.
>> Okay. So even if they were right. Okay. So now now we've
already shifted. We've already shifted from
No, there's no way this is the case.
But if it was the case. Okay, here we go. >> Uh yeah, I
understand what you're saying, Lawi. Yeah, you probably couldn't
actually do it.
>> Trafficking narcotics. The penalty is not instant death.
Are you? Yeah, it is.
And if it's not, it should be.
>> How about that? Are you ridiculous? Oh my. Yeah, why
not?
Really? Why not? Cuz the US usually likes to make it seem like
they don't just decide what the law is for the entire planet.
Makes everybody else uncomfortable. They start to seem like the
evil empire that everybody should rise up against and hide things
from.
Usually. Usually.
>> Who going to stop us? Yeah, exactly. [__]
them. My god, we're only 24 seconds into a two-minute clip. I
don't know if I can [__] get through this. >> I'm
only 3 minutes into his clip. I don't know if I can get through
this
>> The might makes right thing is pretty is pretty um interesting.
I wonder where else asminold applies that in his life.
I'd call that a mask slip, but no. No, he's pretty out there
with it. Makes right is pretty scary, right? I don't know. It's
pretty It's pretty goofy to
If that's like your only principle, I don't know if I I might
like have an aneurysm on air. like, "Oh, it's not that big of
a deal. It doesn't matter that much. Who cares?" And I think
that that has radicalized a lot of people. And I'll view that
and and
>> Okay, I'm sorry. I got to screenshot it. Good one.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm sorry. It is a bit of a good one. Okay, give me a second.
Need that. Need that. We can contrast this now with Do you remember
whenever they had all those text message leaks and it was all
those young Republican people talking about how much they like
and nobody really cared about that anymore? And the reason why
it's because leftwing people have established a basically a standard
and now right-wing people are living up to >> He flipped
the truth exactly on its head. This is insane. >> It's
been the exact opposite my entire adult life. >> It's been
the opposite. There was literally a slogan that the Democrats
had about how much we're >> Michelle. Wait, I feel like
this topic is a bit overblown just because people want to be
anti-Trump.
Wait, the just straight up of the terrorists or whatever. Sorry,
not narot terrorists, the the people smuggling the drugs. I don't
really have a problem with it to be honest with you. I don't
have a problem with them if they're actually drug dealers and
they're smuggling. I don't really have a problem with it. Okay,
personally, I understand most people in my chat don't share that
opinion. That is somewhere where I'm like kind of close to Asmin
Gold. It's like, hey, you're just you're just straight up trying
to create a crime like do a crime coming into my country? Yeah,
I can kill you. But I do think you should actually make sure
they were smuggling drugs first.
That's my personal opinion. I like due process personally. Uh
I like due process, too. I think the issue the issue for me with
the boats is that those people are opting out of like the process
to get into the country. They're opting out. They're living by
a different rule set, right? If that's what they're doing. If
they're coming into your country with drugs, they're opting to
like live by a different rule
You can set different rules for those people, but you have to
know, right? You have to know. That's the thing is you have to
know beyond a shadow of a doubt. This is like the death penalty,
right? You can't you can't be death penaltying people without
concrete evidence that there's like a, you know, a thousand kilos
of on that boat. Can't just be random dudes. Obama came out and
said, "When they go low, we go high." That >> Joe. Bro,
I think one of the first takes I put down on
the record for for like when I started talking about political
content was I was like, why doesn't the US just like take a like
a what do you call it a demilitarized zone and put a of landmines
in it all across their border outside of the scheduled check-ins?
So, you can be sure in international waters. No, I don't think
you can. I That's why I was saying Matt, you missed it. I said
they should they should pull up on those boats. They should pull
up and if you got a bunch of drugs, you're going down.
That's how that's how it should be. But I understand a whole
bunch of people want due process for people who
basically don't give a about you or your >> I get it. A
generation of democratic thought when >> then why' you
guys burn down all the stuff in BLM?
>> Why' you burn down the Teslas? That doesn't sound like
going high. Maybe getting high but not going high. >> Reuben
Rubin, I need you to stop writing for this guy. Okay, stop. Stop.
It's It's getting It's getting rough to watch on another stream.
Okay. >> So, because Michelle Obama said something now
everything is autom Everything that Democrats do is automatically
good.
why didn't I think of that? >> They go low, we go high.
>> And then what happened? The Republicans decided to shatter
the filibuster record under Obama. Obama literally came out and
said, "I I'm going to propose your ideas, Republicans. I'm going
to do the things you say you love. I'm going to do a healthcare
plan that came from the Heritage Foundation, a right-wing think
tank, and Mitt Romney, the Republican, did it in Massachusetts
as the governor. I'm going to do your plan." >> And Republicans
had previously all supported this plan. >> I think the
Republicans treated Obama too harshly, too. Honestly, I I generally
agree with this. I think the Republicans like they they stop
them from appointing Mer.
>> Uh Yep. This is true, Porter Beller. Yeah. Yep. I think
this is a great point to make. I think you don't I think you
make this point and you don't go, "Oh, it's just wrong to keep
drug dealers uh bringing drugs into your country that only want
to harm your country." Right? I think if you I think dying on
that hill, you just shut the up on that point and you say, "Oh,
like this isn't effective drug policing at all. It's not remotely
effective. This is basically just, you know, a pretext for the
US invading Venezuela.
You want to say that? Oh, that's way more. You got me on your
side. Don't like and politically that's what people should be
doing. They shouldn't even hit on this other stuff in my opinion.
Well, at least not in the current political environment. In a
different political environment, if you have like an entirely
different strategy, maybe. But it does not message well to people
objectively. Listen, we could see it basically everywhere that
like the the faith in the American economy is eroding very quickly.
People are not doing well. People are really behind on on their
bills, on everything. Okay? Nobody's in like a great place. Almost
nobody's in like a great place right now.
For as long as this is the case, you're going to have people
who go, "Wait, you're saying we should do stuff that's more expensive
for Americans to help other people outside of America? You
have to be aware of that. You have to be aware of how the messaging
sounds." Eric Garland as uh Supreme Court justice, which I think
Obama did have the purview to do. And throughout his entire tenure
as being president, that did happen. Like I mean, he's right
about this. Yeah, absolutely.
>> Obama, we're against it. WE'RE AGAINST IT. HOW DARE
YOU? >> I think the ACA was and I think that the best way
to tell that the ACA was is that all these different insurance
companies had their their stock go up after it got passed.
The Affordable Care Act, Obamacare
was the most the the main thing that Obamacare was caring for
were the insurance companies and private healthcare companies.
It was mandatory welfare for those companies. It was a joke.
Now, the the
Porterella, you're saying this, but you're wrong. That 30% doesn't
exist.
There's not a single person who gave a about the human rights
of any terrorist getting drone struck in other countries. This
is just the same problem at a different if it in a different
theater. Nobody cares. That's like 3% of people tops. You're
saying 30. I'm I'm telling you it's three at best. You can try
to say it's human rights, but it's human rights for people who
have nothing but like disdain for your country who are trying
to actively harm your country. You cannot win saying, "Oh, I
think everybody should deserve human rights." because it is just
seen as a defense of
The media frames it correctly. Okay, you guys think so.
It will only ever be used as political theater. You are basically
saying this in the same way that other people get mad about Obama
drone striking someone that ended up like collaterally an American
like the guy's kid.
People don't actually care about it. Nobody voted on it. They
only talk about it when it's convenient. Yeah, sure. Nothing
but disdain for your
No concern for the long-term well-being of your country. They
want to extract money from your country in exchange for harming
your country.
Yes, that is.
Would you tell people to feel a lot of concern for like a lot
of concern for the human rights porter of
Larry Ellison? You very concerned about the human rights of Larry
Ellison? You really concerned about what what happens to Larry
Ellison? I will just be your
Reban Rubin donated $3. My pun would have been way more better
than his stupid Tesla pun.
>> Way more better. Yeah, you won. You won. You won. Congratulations,
Reuben. Ruben, thank you.
>> Republicans didn't want what I want, which is universal
healthcare. They don't want that. However,
see, now I feel like I can see into your soul, Porter Beller,
and I know that you're just saying this for the sake of the point,
and you don't actually believe that in your heart of hearts.
You don't. You really don't um what you know like again what
Obama did wasn't good either. >> It's communist for us
to do the healthare plan that we came up with.
>> This is who we're dealing with. They broke the filibuster
record. >> They
uh instantly rejected their own ideas. Obama would do things
like cut small business taxes and they would attack him for it.
Even though again that's their ideas.
>> You want to talk about radicalized
100% is the exact opposite. Democrats and liberals.
Not everyone is soulless like you. I'm telling you that people
have principles until it's um dealing with somebody they hate
or somebody they love
and then they their principles go away.
And I'm telling you that like a ton of people if you frame this
and you if you frame this in the easiest in the most easily framed
way, you just look like kind of unhinged offending
you. You look like you don't care about Americans and you'll
be made to look like you don't care about Americans. And there
are ways you can answer. There are ways you can talk about it
that don't make you seem bad to those people. You can say like
different messages for different places. That's probably fine.
But um yeah, I'm just saying that to me like the political messaging
really
really hurts at this particular political moment. >> Leftists
have been >> like when you're just like no, human rights
are important. Every everybody should everybody should have due
process including like the drug dealers bringing drugs into our
country. It's it's like yeah, I agree with that and yeah, I understand
holding that principle is important.
I'm I'm saying that I wouldn't talk about it. I would hold to
that principle. I would say if I could if listen, you gave me
the choice to vote for somebody who is who is doing that, I would
vote against them. You gave me the choice to bomb those people
or not, I would not bomb those people. Right? But I'm telling
you about what I would want people to talk about in this
Uh yeah, you you're just wrong about my personal opinion here.
Just some internet chick. I'm telling you, I'm talking about
messaging. what I think is like actually effective messaging
right
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, for sure. >> Uh I don't know,
Crisp. Let me see what you just typed. An analogy. When people
say noy girls, they don't really mean always know girls. Similar
to due process, sometimes action is needed that doesn't leave
room for due process. No, that's not what I mean. No. >> Uh
people people were negative about Obama. Yeah, definitely. I
think that was stupid. It was stupid then. It's still stupid.
>> Atticalized by Republicans being so
>> Trump tried to coup the government. Trump lost an election
to Joe Biden.
Who's Nobody's advocating for arbitrarily suspending human rights.
No, nobody's Nobody is advocating for arbitrarily suspending
human rights, are they? It's not arbitrary.
It's a very open and obvious part of the ocean where if you go
with a little boat and you got drugs on it, you're going to get
bombed. It's not arbitrary.
It's not arbitrary at all. And then he did fake elector slates.
>> Mhm. which was illegal by the way, but he got got away
with it. >> Then they had January 6, the violence at January
6th. Even after the violence, Trump was still making phone calls
saying, "Don't certify Joe Biden."
And this is the difference between I think a lot of liberals
and
people like me. Like leftists like this will bend over backwards
to justify why it was actually a good thing that we spent an
entire year burning down autozones, looting 7-Elevens, and destroying
every city during BLM. they'll bend over backwards justifying
why it's actually a good thing that you're destroying Teslas
or why it's a good thing that you had people that were uh you
know like Jay Jones who's tweeting not tweeting sorry having
conversations fantasizing about people he's running against uh
uh politically right the difference between like I think that
myself and people like him is that I can easily say January 6
was a bad thing it was awful >> uh guys this thing that
like the person I like the the thing they did that's actually
uh okay if you're going to catch me on just like the grammar
of what I said then yes most when I say all I mean like 90 95%
right I'm saying all because it's just easier it's like a it's
like an effective rhetorical way of speaking when you when you
say it's like overwhelming it's not like it's not even like 80
it's not like 70 it's like 90 95 99%
of people uh but that's probably the only thing I'm going to
say on that there was one other Uh, let's see here. There was
another point I wanted to look at here. Lost it. >> Lost
it. Go. >> It's bad.
Like the problem is that in a lot of cases, people like Kyle
are unwilling to seed any ground or to look at anything objectively.
They see everything through the lens of what their side wants
and they're not looking at it in any sort in an objective or
realistic way. Obviously, January 6 was bad. Now, I think that
it was very clearly misrepresented and if you don't think so,
then you know, maybe the should hire you as a lawyer because
they admitted that it was misrepresented and aped
that Trump was shown on and is that like what most people saw?
I didn't read the story. I had the story in my docket yesterday.
Was that like was the version of this was that like broadcast
and everybody in the world used that same footage or is the footage
I saw from like the New York Times or something the actual footage?
Cuz I don't understand what could have been doed in this one
speech to make it look like
oh suddenly like actually Trump is totally misunderstood.
But like I'm willing to be open to it, but to me that story just
seems unlikely that this was the only footage anybody saw and
everyone has had the worst understanding of Trump's speech forever.
Yeah, it's just two clips, but was it just from a documentary?
Is it just a documentary? It's so stupid that people are acting
like this is um totally misrepresenting. That's what everybody's
thinking on this subject on January 6th was. It was based on
this one documentary. Off >> apologize for it. So uh very
clearly it was misrepresented. But even in its best representation,
it was still bad. But you don't need to come up with excuses
for it. This is the problem.
And that's the whole point that I'm making. That was the entire
point of my clip is that whenever Republicans, like what I was
saying, do something bad like January
people like me at least call it out and say, "Hey, that was pretty
bad. You shouldn't do that." I didn't see that. >> Okay.
But you don't do anything about it. Um, it's it's bad. What do
you want me to say? It's bad. What do you want me to say? It's
bad. What do you want me to say? Well, I want you to to literally
call out the actors. Literally say, "What was bad about it?"
Because as Oh, the riot looked really bad, guys. Does he talk
about the electors plot at all? >> That happen with Tesla
bombings. I don't see that happen with Jay Jones.
How about that? >> Wait, a lot of people said the Jay Jones
stuff was unhinged, was bad.
A lot of people say that. I can say that. Like, oh yeah, he clearly
like he clearly was saying you would never say publicly. He clearly
was saying some that is like really bad to say. Oh yeah, like
maybe their kids got to die for them to actually learn how the
world works. Yeah, obviously.
>> Very interesting.
>> He was asking politicians not to certify Joe Biden.
>> That's insane. That is insane.
And so they do the extreme. They do the crazy. To be fair, this
was after 4 years of them trying to delegitimize Trump's presidency
by him being being connected to Russia. This happened even before
he became president that they were trying to delegitimize him.
So, I don't think that 2020, the election there, I don't think
that was the culmination of election denial. I think that it
started with Donald Trump. Now, in I'd say 2012, like when was
the last election? I guess 2000 was a little bit uncertain because
of the hanging Chad thing with like Gore and Bush, but overall
before that, I mean, I feel like most elections people pretty
much accepted them. But I would say that even with denying the
election, there was remember the hashotmy president where people
were saying that, oh, he's just, you know, got elected because
of Russia. People being mad about Donald Trump being president
is equivalent to an
and meticulously architected attempt to overthrow the results
of an election to overthrow the government basically for a coup.
Cool.
This is this is the this is peak as gold content right now. Peak
Asmin gold right here. So really I mean I while I while I do
say that January 6 was a bad thing, I don't think that again
Republicans did not invent election denial. I think that Democrats
at that point had spent four years doing it with uh with Donald
Trump to begin with. And it turned out that all that, by the
way, was he will not divide us. Yep, there it is. >> But
somehow we're the problem. >> Really weird how he's celebrating
ACA while also celebrating the assassination of a CEO who benefited
the most from things like ACA. I don't know if he celebrated
the Luigi stuff. I have no
>> We're the ones who never criticize our own. Are you
kidding me? How quickly do Democrats throw throw each other under
the bus? Not quickly enough with Jay Jones, for example, and
that one just happened. Yeah, you can go back and find an example
of something stupid that happened during Obama, but I can go
back a week ago and find something stupid that you guys did.
That's the problem. How far back do we have to go to find something
stupid that Republicans did?
90 seconds. HEY, WHERE ARE THE Epste files? Hey, does your Republican
president not suck in the of a Democrat
Right. Is your Republican president now not openly trying to
like with somebody who's trying to release the rest of the Epstein
files?
Like Trump is openly trying to obiscate the Epstein files. He's
been doing so for months now. Asmin Gold doesn't really talk
about it, does he?
And I, by the way, I don't even think there's anything in there.
I think I thought it was like total conspiracy theory to think
there was anything in there. And now with how openly Trump has
gone from taking he took one of his strongest advocates in Congress,
Marjgerie Taylor Green, he's now trying to like destroy her career
for just wanting the Epstein files out. It's crazy. I have no
idea what this is referring to. Hold on. Give me two seconds.
I'll be right back. Got to use the bathroom. Remember Al Franken?
Al Franken was a senator. There was a picture that he took where
he was >> fake grabbing somebody's while they were sleeping.
That picture came out. He used to be a comedian, by the way.
He didn't actually touch the woman, but it was like fake grabbing
the and like laughing at it and joking about it. >> He
had to resign because other Democrats threw him immediately under
the bus. >> Are you out of your minds? I I keep saying
minds. Are you out of your mind? >> I mean, it's just it's
this is ridiculous. This is absolutely ridiculous. Nothing could
be further from the truth. It was Donald Trump who came along
and he sort of he sort of defined this idea of be a bull in a
china shop. Never apologize. always always plow through. >> He
did apologize for the grabber by the thing. He did apologize
for that, but I don't think he meant it, but he did apologize
and then eventually people just move on and you're good. >> So,
he started that. >> We're just getting to the time now
where Democrats are finally catching. >> Uh, I don't really
think that's entirely true. I feel like Hillary Clinton said
a number of bad things about Trump voters as well. >> Uh,
yeah. It's it's again the one example, right? It's like volume.
Like I would even go I'd give you Trump. You can count every
Trump comment as a two and every Hillary comment as a 10 or one
in five if you want to, you know, knock it down. And I still
think Trump probably, you know, 5 to 10xes Hillary Clinton, right?
At at minimum. Like even with a 5 to1 advantage on points for
all the comments he makes, it's like it's the volume difference.
The volume difference is insane.
Like it's it's pretty common up to that, right? That's just starting
to happen now. And thank God god it is. Cuz here's the deal.
We can only have civility into quorum if both sides agree to
civility and >> it's that simple. As soon as the Republicans
go you then then we have to say you back. It's like with the
jerrymandering fight. By the way, Asmin who's the one that gerrymandered
first. It was Texas and the Republicans that said we're just
going to gerrymander and steal a bunch of >> the recent
one seats and turn them
>> Well, I mean, wait a wait a minute. stealing. Jerrymander
is fundamentally stealing, by the way. And both Democrats and
Republicans do this. They've been doing this for ever.
Greg Abbott did that cuz Trump told him to do that. >> And
then >> true. And he should have done it. And all the other
Republican states should do it, too. >> Had that had to
happen before
you had Nsome step up and say, "All right, if you're going to
do that, then we're going to counter Jerry Mander in California."
Which, by the way, this is a this is a shadow argument that he's
fighting against.
I never criticized Gavin Newsome for doing that.
I never said that. Of course, I understand why he'd want to do
that. Of course, you're going to want to consolidate power for
your side. Obviously, yeah, I was never even against it. So,
I didn't even say that.
That's not even it.
>> Didn't start that. The Democrats didn't start that.
>> Republicans started that. We responded in kind. Democrats,
>> that's fine. Yeah. You guys want to do Proposition 50?
That's fine. Yeah. Okay. Sure. I I think that's fair. >> And
liberals and leftists responded in
>> So he hasn't exactly wrong. >> Okay. He hasn't
exactly >> not even what I'm sayingly backwards.
>> These are unhinged and out of control and radical. >> I
thought they connected there for a >> We have been dragged
into having to do the same to keep things even. Stevens, >> you're
completely right. all of the all of the Republican crashs, all
of the massive protests that Republicans are having, destroying,
you know, throwing bricks at people at ICE, uh, you know, trying
to get in front of the cars, screaming at them, uh, destroying
property. Again, going back to the BLM riots, burning down Teslas,
uh, Charlie Kirk, I mean, there were two assassinations on Trump
as well, or at least attempt. I mean, at at what point do you
really I mean, how long can this go on for, guys?
How how long can we just keep making up the ICE attacks? Yeah,
exactly. What is going on with >> Cuz if they're going
to jerrymander and we say we we're not going to do it on principle,
then they just >> Nobody said that. Nobody. This is again,
this is a argument that I never made >> everything period.
As far as the I can
>> in a very weird way, once the other side starts cheating,
in order to make it more fair, you also have to start cheating.
Once they start being insane to keep it fair, you also have to
be equally insane in the opposite direction. Okay?
I mean, but let's be honest, Kyle, you guys are going to be insane
no matter
It might be convenient
that Republicans do some things that are insane, but you were
going to be insane anyway. All right, let's be real.
Like, it's the only way to do it. And again, he flips it and
pretends like it's the Democrats who are totally unhinged and
that made the Republicans radicalized. Get the out of here. Also,
>> well, I I think if you want to talk about a policy decision
that's like very unhinged that makes people radicalized. I think
that a good example of that is the uh trans and sports. So, uh
dude, it's like uh honestly
just give up. just give up. Go populist. Start lying.
It's like you're trying to play like this perfect game. It's
like playing a um
it's like playing a glass cannon build in in any video game,
any single player video game that's like a skillbased like let's
say um like a minimum bigger game in Dark Souls or something,
right? It's like it's just that like that's what that's what
you have to do trying to argue for Democrats right now. Just
like hey here's like a thousand things you did. here's 1,000
hits on the boss. And the boss is like, "Uh, I just hit you once."
Yeah, you're you're dead. You're dead. You're dead. >> also
like uh trans kids using uh bathrooms. Now, you can make an argument
that this isn't really a big issue, but if it's not a big issue,
then why are you fighting it so much? So, I think that that's
a radicalization issue that does affect average people, that
makes people think that Democrats are ideologues and disconnected
from reality. So if you're trying to make an argument that for
example uh biological men should compete with biological women
in sports especially in you know high school sports or middle
school sports uh you're really kind of this in my opinion I got
to get through that argument is of the same validity of flat
earth. >> I don't know I don't know what Kyle's opinion
is on that. Yeah, I agree. Like basically kids shouldn't be participating
the same sports or sorry, you shouldn't have trans people participating
participating in sports
uh against like in their transition to gender after
or I guess just one way. You shouldn't have male to female transgender
people participating in high school sports if there's like scholarships
on the line or in university sports. I just I give you that and
we just move on. >> This is a flat earth argument. So if
a person gives an argument like that, it is so radical and so
extreme. >> Yeah. I don't know why you said especially
middle school. It's like that's probably where the problem is
minimized. It's not like it's not nothing, but it's probably
far more minimal. You're not losing like scholarships or anything
in middle school for for this happening, right?
>> and not that you would lose scholarships if they just
banned, you know, trans people or certain certain people with
certain hormone levels from participating in college sports.
you'd probably lose, you know, some of the your ability, I don't
know, to do your best. I don't know, maybe it'd be demotivating.
In any case, it's like something I don't care about. Like, ban
all trans people from sports for all I care. Not actually, but
like at some point I'm so done talking about it. It's like just
ban everybody from all sports. Ban sports. Can we get off the
topic? So devoid of any logic, rationality, biology, science,
or even common sense that you have to assume that this person's
mental facilities are compromised and you can't trust other things
that they're going to say. That's the big difference. And so
I think he he's he's using examples of policy things and the
examples he used were bad. But I'll give him an example that
actually does make sense that does radicalize I think Republicans
in a lot of cases. And I think that's a great example of it.
And so like and that's that's one of the things I think people
see that and they're like what the this is so crazy. This is
so extreme. Nobody could actually believe this and then they
go all the way. That's it. I I just don't see how wanting to
remove people who are here illegally is the same as trying to
hurt people who are just doing their job fulfilling that. Well,
it's because So you have to understand that Kyle would never
want an illegal immigrant or somebody living in his house without
his permission. I don't think he would want that. However, he
has no problem letting people live in other areas that he's probably
has nothing to do with. Like I mean, Kyle's a relatively successful
YouTube guy. He he does well for himself. I'm sure he makes a
lot of money and he probably lives in an area where there is
a minimal amount of uh friction that's been caused by illegal
migr.
Sometimes I sometimes find myself wanting to just abandon all
the trans rights issues. I don't believe in them or sorry, I
believe in them, but I'm not sure I'm ready to for another Trumpesque
figure if that's the cost. H
I don't think most people like a lot of the trans right stuff.
I do believe that's solid still. Maybe it's been frayed a little
bit. Okay, maybe it's been frayed just a touch in the modern
political environment, but I believe arguing for people's like
ability to transition as they're adult and when they're adults.
I don't think anyone's against that. I don't think that's ever
been something that people don't like.
I think there's
probably you could chip away at the trans youth medicine thing
as well, like youth youth health treatment. What
trans youth medical care? It's something like this. Gender gender
care for youth. God damn it. Whatever that is, you could probably
chip away at that, but it went way too fast and it went way before
the studies were in. And that's the problem, right? Not gender
affirming care. No, no, no. Trans. It's like you No, it's not
gender reaffirming care. It's like the idea of doing it for kids.
It's not gender It's not gender affirming care at all. And he
also has a job that is in no like risk of being displaced by
illegal migration either. So really, you have somebody who's
totally disconnected from this issue that is telling other people
that they should necessarily uh they should deal with it, right?
And so this is the person you're watching, by the way. Who is
this? This land is by the Colorado border plane. It's pretty
cool. I have no idea why it looks like this.
It's called farming. What? >> Oh, that's pretty goofy.
That's a Wait, why why did he tweet this? Is this Is this a joke?
Is this a joke,
bro? What is this? Why does it look like this? This is crazy.
I I get like how you could say that if you're from a big city,
you never flown and you kind of never left the big city or you've
only driven along the freeways, right? I do kind of get it. No,
these are just fields like farming field. Like it's just farming
farmland, right? They're different crops planted on different
plots. Different plots harvested at different times. It's not
even frost
or it's not necessarily frost. Maybe it is frost actually in
this case, November 2nd and and it looks like stuff's moved through
it. But he's talking about like the patchwork.
The patchwork is what he doesn't know about here.
It's It's just very funny.
Wow. Can you believe that? Oh god. Yeah, this is the guy. Yeah,
there he is. Oh >> W Kyle, >> what what a what a
guy, huh? How about that? Delete your account. Yeah. So, I I
hope he's farming now. Maybe he's
>> Seemed like um you know, like Republicans are put upon
to have to condemn a Republican group chat where they were like
loving.
>> That should be easy. That should be a low [__]
bar, bro. >> Yeah. Not as low as wanting to uh you know,
have the kids of >> God damn it. Why can't he just Why
can't Asold ever just go, you know what, you're right. But also,
why does he have to go Why does he have to what about every single
criticism?
every single one and so many of them without actual tangible
defense or or even something to think about it, right? He's just
like, you don't know that for sure. People that you disagree
with politically.
I think loving is bad. Absolutely, it's bad. But if you're not
willing to condemn somebody who fantasizes about having the children
of his political opponents, then how can you expect anybody else
to capitulate what you want?
I mean, what are we doing here? It's a joke. Yeah. And also,
all those people, here's what's funny about it, is >> this
is probably true, right? It's probably true that Jay Jones's
texts are about as bad as the Republican youth uh whatever the
[__] the young Republican group chats that leaked,
right? Given that those guys are like staffers, Jay Jones just
got made attorney general.
I'd say you should have the same level of condemnation for those
things.
But that all I think youth is worse. I think there's significantly
more reason to believe that they were joking. Dingleingis, I
don't think Jay Jones was joking. I don't I think his friend
was like, "Hey, don't joke about that and he's like, "I'm not
joking. [__] you."
I I don't think he was joking. I think a lot of those those people
in the in the youth chat, you could at least say they're joking
about some of the stuff. Those people from that group were removed.
They were removed from that uh I think it's like a young Republican
society or something like that. They were all removed. So, for
a joke, they got removed for telling the truth in private. Jay
Jones got elected to attorney general. I think that we have a
problem here.
But to them, it's not like I I think you say that's horrible.
I wish I wish you just say that's horrible. I wish Republicans
hadn't put us in this
I wish that a Republican party existed that I could vote for
so I didn't have to vote for the guy who said he thinks it would
be funny or he he he dreams about the his opponent's kids getting
killed in a school shooting because they vote against gun control.
I wish I could denounce that guy and move on from him. I wish
I had the option. That's what I wish. Okay. You have all these
conservatives that wouldn't defend Jay Jones. Well, that that's
the main person I'm talking about, right? And it was in the context
of that. It was this crazy stuff. And there's never a point of
moral authority that, you know, any liberal can have when you're
the one justifying, you know, shutting down a college or you're
the one justifying being violent to an officer. Are you confused?
I'm talking about the um like whenever the pro Palestine protesters
came to like places like UCLA and they were violent towards other
people that were trying to just do do their work. Uh they blocked
access to certain buildings. They destroyed property. And
it depends on what you mean. Dingling. Does he want it in a way
that he's going to make it happen? No.
Nope. I don't think he wants it in a way that it's going to happen.
I think he basically said they should they should feel the pain
of the policies they advocate for is kind of what he's saying,
which you could say is different,
but one, he shouldn't be doing it as a big political figure,
and two,
it's still a pretty like saying you wish they would have that
happen so they could understand why their policies are bad is
an understandable thing, but to like double down on it sounds
goofy as doesn't sound serious. Uh, it's pretty serious. It's
like pretty annoying. >> And uh they didn't follow police
orders. that that was I know you might be confused by that but
that's that's why I was discussing >> the one justified
uh you know destroying property somebody's call or something
like that they all got blacklist fire department jobs yes but
I understand that structurally but that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what happened to them what matters is how the public perceives
it and I think that this is continuing to become the case I think
that any conservative at this point should totally stop purity
testing because left people don't purity test themselves and
>> he's so mad okay all right let's hear it okay here we
go the extent to which this guy has no idea what he's talking
about it's like >> okay I get it I don't know what I'm
talking about I'm an idiot I'm a big stupid okay let's let's
hear why >> got into politics 7 seconds ago like literally
just 7 seconds ago, HE WAS LIKE, "HUH, POLITICS. WHAT'S THAT?
I HAVE OPINIONS on it." >> Great. Is this going to be Trump
talking about Fentes? Yeah, I heard that this happened. Somebody
told me this
>> Hold on. We'll pull it up right now. Breaking
Nick Fentes news. In a follow-up question about Nick Fentes,
Trump acknowledges he met Fent with Fuentes and Yay, formerly
known as Kanye West, but refuses to disavow Fentes or specify
Oh, never mind. Wait,
hold on. But refuses to disavow Fentes or specifies his role
in the GOP, reiterating that Tucker can interview whoever he
likes. Oh, this is new. I thought so he
refuses to disavow Fuentes. That's funny because he disavowed
Fentes kind of back then. He just said, "I don't know who this
guy is. I don't support people like this."
Right. Now he's not disavowing again. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Is this all the Fentes part of this? I thought there was more
to this. Right. It says in a follow-up question. Is there another
post then? So, there's this and then there's a follow-up question.
Hold on. Okay. Hold on. We'll do the We'll do the Tucker Carlson
one first. Okay. This the first >> Tucker Carlson recently
had a friendly interview with anti-semite Nick Fuentes.
Tucker Carlson.
>> Wait, did you catch that? We're 10 seconds into the
clip and something amazing just happened. You guys all caught
that, right? He didn't say, "Wait, who did Tucker interview?"
He went, "Wait, who interviewed Nick Fentes?" He didn't say,
"Who is Nick Fentes?" He said, "Who interviewed Nick Fentes?"
He wasn't asking like who Nick Fentes is. He's like, "Wait, who
interviewed him? You caught that, right? Listen again. >> The
formula. Mr. President, Tucker Carlson recently had a friendly
interview with anti-semite Nick Fuentes.
>> Who did? >> Tucker Carlson. >> Oh, yeah.
Tucker Carlson. Okay. All right. Wait. Is there content for me
to Is there content? Hold on.
>> You think Tucker Carlton could play in the Republican
party, the conservative moving party? >> Well, I found
him to be good. I mean, he said good things about me over the
years and he's I think he's good. We've had some good interviews.
I did an interview with him where we had 300 million hits. You
know that. Look, I can't tell him. Will you let me finish? You
are the >> Dude,
they they so badly want this on tape that they're going to make
Trump I guarantee you if you have Trump in the right environment,
you can make him disavow anybody. Okay. But when you're like
when you're pushing him like this, when you interrupt him to
GO, WILL YOU DISAVOW NICK FUENTES? He's going to say no. He's
going to tell you to off, right? He's they they pushed him to
this. I'm not even joking.
him. Will you let me finish by saying you are the worst? You're
with Bloomberg, right? You are the worst. I don't know why they
even have you,
>> dude. What the Holy [__] That's the president
of the United States. You suck at your job. They shouldn't even
have you here. >> Uh, we've had some great interviews with
Tucker Carlson. But you can't tell him who to interview. I mean,
if he wants to interview Nick Fuentes, I don't know much about
him, but if he wants to do it, get >> Dude, he totally
knows exactly who that is. Nobody's failed to state that name.
He is like hyper up. Oh, no.
Like, I'm sorry. It's He's not going I don't know who that. He
says, "I don't know much about him." He gets the name exactly
how every Republican like influencer says the name.
That's crazy. >> Get the word out. Let them, you know,
people have to decide. Ultimately, people have to decide. >> Put
the word out on Nick Fuentes. Hold on. What? >> But if
he wants to do it, get the word out. Let him, you know, people
have to decide. Ultimately, people have to
>> That's like an open a vowel of Tucker, right? That's
an open like, yeah, you can interview whoever you want. Get the
word out. Make sure people know who this guy is. You want to
cancel this guy? No. Make sure people know who he is. That that's
like an open avow of Nick
That's crazy. dinner with Nick Fuentes at Mara Lago a few years
ago. What role should he play in the conservative >> Well,
I didn't know he was coming and he was with as you know somebody
Kanye
and Kanye asked if he could have dinner and he brought Nick.
I didn't know Nick at the time and uh he did he came and along
with a few other people he brought a few people with him.
uh meeting people, talking to people like for somebody like Tucker,
that's what they do. You know, people are controversial. Some
are, some aren't. I'm not controversial, so I like it that
>> With Nick,
he's I'm not controversial at all.
I'm not controversial. So, listen, these people can do whatever
they want. That's interesting. That's interesting. this. >> Hey,
I'm a stone cold white nationalist and I love and I don't want
INDIANS HERE AND I'M NOT A DEMOCRAT, OKAY? And I'm not woke and
I'm not liberal.
Okay. Damn. Damn.
Okay, that was a quick update on Trump made some comments on
Fentes.
I
All right, fair enough. Hold on. There was one more thing here.
Trump comment on Marjgery Trader Green. It's not Taylor Green.
is now Marjorie Trader
This guy's This guy's on point with the names. Uhoh. >> Be
at danger because of the rhetoric. >> Her life is in danger.
>> Who's that? >> Marjorie Taylor Green. She says
>> Marjorie Trader Green. Uh I don't think her life is
in danger. I don't think, frankly, I don't think any >> Wait,
what's the penalty for traitor for uh treason again? >> Anybody
cares about her?
>> Damn.
He's going off on all these people
That's like a That's like a classic Trump interview right there.
That's That's classic. Okay. Refuses to disavow controversial
figure, you know, tells a reporter she sucks and she she shouldn't
have her job, then calls one of his opponents a goofy nickname
and says she's a loser and nobody thinks about her. Damn.
Yeah, we'll cover more on this later, Kger. I I got your messages.
Thank you. We'll we'll cover the MTG Trump stuff as well. All
right, but we need to finish off the Asmin Gold Kyle Klinsky
video. Let's keep going. We're getting close to the end now.
I bailed on the Kyle Klinsky video pretty shortly after he finishes
reacting to the clip. We'll see how far Asmin Gold goes. I don't
think I'm going to go all the way through his clip.
Asmin Gold is maybe if there's good stuff after we can come back
to it later. I'm not going to do this whole video in one sitting
if I don't have to. >> You don't know what you're talking
about. You know, you don't know what you're talking about. That's
the thing that gets me. >> Well, here's what I think is
very interesting. Even using his own argumentation, doesn't that
make him look kind of stupid? Is that even from somebody who's
been involved in politics for 17 seconds, even they can tell
that there's obviously a massive discrepancy? Yeah, good one,
Koser. Good one. You guys don't know Koser is uh he's like Nick
Fentes's best friend, okay? One of his best friends. One of his
like three best friends in the whole world. And he comes into
this chat sometimes and he says, you know, maybe the Epstein
files are a Democrat hoax after all. They're not. They're not.
There's obviously a huge double standard that's at play and I
think the whole the whole country can see it. So maybe you're
too involved. Maybe you're in too deep and you're not able to
just see the reality of it.
Something your chatter's calling you wrong? Yeah. Well, maybe
this is where they learned it from. He also commented on Jay
Jones immediately. >> Uh could maybe check this out at
some point. Dustin Suggs. We'll see where we get to missing it.
It was about mass shootings and it was about the >> What
was Kyle's best point in this video? Um I mean in general he's
just correct on a whole bunch of his points that Asen Gold saying
that Republicans don't get any like leniency from Democrat from
anyone and Democrats get all of the leniency in the world. That's
obviously insane when your president literally came up with a
scheme to steal an election and then was reelected.
That's just at a base level incredibly insane. His opponent's
kids, it was like the only way they'd understand the pain of
that is if their kids got right basically saying like you're
not >> that's not what he said. >> Republican you're
not going to support legislation to you know change everybody's
reality violence unless it impacts you. So Republicans lied about
that and pretended like he wants to murder the kid of his opponent.
That's everybody knows that's but that's what they ran with and
the texts were so bad that people thought well this will be a
layup for Republicans. Wrong. So the betting markets had the
Republican favor to win for so long and literally just last night
the results are rolling and boom flipped and then Jay Jones ended
up winning. That really >> Wow. I guess that sure proves
me wrong.
>> Yeah, that's to >> I don't I don't know what Kyle's
argument is here. Not what I was talking about at all, right
guys?
>> Yeah, we saw the text messages. >> I know he knows.
He doesn't know what the [__] he's talking about.
You allow other people to create the >> By the way, just
totally total aside about how I don't know what I'm talking about
at all. Literally no examples, no reason for saying this. Just
that I'm stupid and I don't know what I'm talking about. I guess
either either my chatters learned it from him or he learned it
from my chatters. Does he even address what I said? No, he didn't
even address it for you. All you're doing is you're allowing
your enemy to define how you lose. And basically, you can see
how they had no problem voting for Jay Jones, right? This is
a guy that like fantasized about, you know, his political opponent's
children. >> He wasn't arguing. That's a lie. You're lying.
You're lying. He's all right. So, if you refer over here to the
text
so these are the leaked text messages that Jay Jones had. If
those guys die before me, I will go to their funerals and on
their graves, send them out a washing something. Three people,
two bullets. Gilbert and Paul pot. >> Okay, this one this
one's not that bad. That's a hypothetical. That's like it's not
a joke, but it's a hypothetical. You're just saying these guys
suck. >> But gets two bullets in the head. So, not only
is he and this is also multiple because they are those guys.
This is plural, right? So, he's talking about multiple people.
And then I wasn't attacking you. I was trying to understand your
logic. And I told Yes, I've told you this before. You were talking
about how So, right here, you were talking about hoping that
Jennifer Gilbert's children would die.
Yeah, I think I told you guys when I was when I was following
this myself.
I think I said that's where Asthold's going to like hold Kyle's
feet to the fire if he responds is Kyle sort of totally downplays
what JJ Jones says
like completely. He's like, "No, it's not like that at all. He
didn't say anything like that. That's you're just lying." And
then it's like, "Oh, yeah. I think their kids do have to die
in a school shooting for them to understand that gun control
is important."
It's like, uh, wait, that is a pretty crazy thing to say. No
problem voting for Jay Jones, right? This is the guy that like
fantasized about, you know, his political opponent's children.
>> He wasn't arguing. That's a lie. You're >> Do
you know who disagrees with Kyle?
Jay Jones. Jay Jones disagrees with you.
He says, "Yes, I've told you this before, guys. Don't listen
to Jay Jones about what J >> You were talking about hoping
Jennifer Gilbert's children would die." Yep.
You were talking about how you were hoping Jennifer Gilbert's
children would die. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Jones said, "No, no, no. Listen to me and
I'm going to tell you what he really meant to say. This is the
text message. It's right here." Oh, oh, wait, wait. I I'll go
even farther here. And then, so there isn't a point blank. You've
done I'm a question. Do I think that Todd and Jennifer are evil
and that they're breeding little fascists and this is Todd and
>> I mean, no, no, no, no, no.
Hold on, Porter Beller. Unfortunately, by the transcript, that's
that's fantasizing. That's like you were talking about how you
about hoping Jennifer Gilbert's children would die. that is thinking
about daydreaming about how their children would die. And he's
like, "Yes, I I do I do I do fantasize about that." Fantasizing.
He's just dreaming. He wants that to happen. He thinks that's
that would be good if that happened. He He's leaning into that
and saying, "Yes." Now, I think it's more nuanced than that.
And he is trying to like kind of gigachad right here. That's
what that's what I think. I say quotes. It's like gay to just
say it. But he's trying to do if you guys remember the Mr. Girl
talking point, the like age of the gigachad thing where you like
sort of just say, "Yeah, that is bass. That is cool." And you
just kind of lean it. He's trying to do that. It's a little goofy.
Obviously a little goofy.
I think he's got like a more subtle point here. Meant to say
>> this is the text message. It's right here. Oh. Oh, wait.
Wait. I I'll go even farther here. And then so there isn't a
point blank. I'm a question. Do I think that would die? You tripled
down. Yeah, exactly, guys. But hey, don't believe any of this,
okay? It's all a lie. Jay Jones actually was lying in his private
text messages to somebody else that got leaked later on. And
Kyle actually knows what he meant to say, though. thought Gilbert
was his opponent. I understand
>> Yeah. Don't listen to Jay Jones. He's taking his own
words out of context. Like he literally goes like here one more
one more time about, you know, his political opponent's children.
>> He wasn't Are you That's a lie. You're lying. You're
lying. He said like he said it like Yes. Kyle never actually
says, as far as I remember, he never actually talks about the
comments in the kids, right? He talks about the Paul Pot joke
or something, but I don't think he talks about the comments in
the kids, which to me seems pretty bad. So, I've told you this
before. Only when people feel pain personally do they move on
policy as a response to you were talking about hoping her children
would die. You just look it up. Like, why would you even say
this? This is the guy that's trying to make the argument from
authority that he's the political person you should be listening
to and you couldn't even look up the text messages.
Okay. Fantasizing
about them dying is not equal to fantasizing about them uh killing
them. No, it's not. But they're both like really bad. They're
both like way over the line to be putting out there. Um, now
I thought to me it was like, okay, if he sent that to like an
ex and the ex leaked them, I think you're allowed to have private
thoughts like that that you understand you can't let out publicly.
But I think he sent those to like a political opponent. I think
he was talking to like somebody he talked to politically. Like
I think that was a Republican he was talking to or something,
right? Which is insane. Three people are in an elevator
pot and his and my Republican opponent. What do you And you only
have two bullets. What do you do with two bullets? And he says
both go in his opponent. That's obviously a joke. And do you
guys think that this is a person that was joking? I don't think
that it was a joke. I don't think he was joking about this. Now,
I think that this is the reality. I think that he probably wouldn't
actually do that. He's just a weird mad. However, I don't think
that he was saying >> he's not he's he is not talking about
this as a punch line. Be a joke if Trump said the same thing.
>> No, it would be a constitutional crisis. >> of
course, if >> I'm sorry, there's just to me there's not
there's not like an insane amount of
between like wishing they would die and saying that like I fantas
There there's like some daylight. I understand, but not in terms
of like a politician.
It's like there's like a bar you have to reach for it to be like
way over the line. And fantasizing about somebody's kids dying
is already way over that line. If you just want to say you don't
care about the line at all, I totally am fine with people saying
that.
That's fine. Just don't soy about other people violating the
line anymore. Right. Trump said this. He would be farming it
so hard. Everybody knows it. >> Joke is this is how evil
these Republicans are. That's the joke, right? By the way, never
even talked about the thing with the kids. Never even talked
about it. Oh, he wants to kill. No, he doesn't. And by the way,
>> greeting little fascists. >> Everybody knows that.
The right knows that. Is it as [__] Absolutely. Was
it private and not meant to go public? Abso [__]
But he doesn't actually want to kill his opponent. And by the
way, >> well, I mean, so were the I mean, so were the Republican
group chat that went public, too. >> That's why he [__]
won. And thank God he did. Wait, I did I missed this
dude. Actually, literally look at the Hold on. Wait, Kyle might
be cooking a little bit. Jay Jones was getting crushed in the
polls and then at some point those texts got released and people
were like, "Oh, this guy's actually kind of based. He wants his
put his kids to die. Let's go. We're up. We're up big, guys."
>> Okay. All right. Finally, now we're having a conversation.
So, it's not that he didn't say it. It's that he did say it and
it was good. Okay. Good. Now, we're having a real conversation.
All right. So, it's not that Yeah, you agree with it.
So, now it's a good thing. Yes, it's not happening, but if it
is happening, it's good that it happened. That was fast because
guess what? It's the exact opposite of what you're saying, Asmin
Gold. Finally, Democrats have gotten it and woken up. This is
the only way forward. >> Finally, they've realized that
the solution is to kill the children of their opponents. >> Okay.
Well, how about that? >> All right. Well, um, crazy policy
there >> for us because Trump made this politics the rule
of the day. He made it like this. Let's remember Let's remember
here's what Trump and and MAGA, here's what they've referred
to Democrats as during the Trump era. The enemy within
>> He's reading them out. Okay. So, what I find to be funny
about this is that yes, Trump has used negative words about Democrats,
but how many times was Trump called a How many times was he called
a racist? How many times was he called a Russian asset? How many
times were his protesters or sorry, his uh what do you call uh
his like supporters called that? Um Hillary Clinton called the
people who supported Trump a basket of deplorables. Like we can
trade uh lists of bad names. >> No, you can't. You can't
go
bar for bar, line for line, on all the bad things Democrats say
versus all the bad things Republicans say. And you will sit there
for a hundred years as Kyle rattles off all of the things and
you get like four. That's the thing. Asminold should be willing
to go through this. Go through the list. The list of Democrat
things is like eight and the list of Republican things is like
8,000. It's not close all day. Like I mean the fact is that both
of them have been doing that and they call Trump a calling him
a fascist. Everything like that. Calling him during 2016. That's
crazy. Crazy thing to say. >> Terrorists vermin. Why did
he do the correction for only 2016? radical lunatics. I would
say calling somebody vermin radical or a lunatic is not even
remotely in the same category as calling somebody a >> I
don't even think they're remotely
>> Demonic evil demonic. Yeah, it's not even remotely close.
Oh, they Oh, they don't call Trump evil. What are we talking
about?
Fascist. Marxist. >> Who called him? Who called Trump an
communist wonder? Garbage. The enemy of the people. Treasonous
animals. Degenerates haters. Low lives. This is how they talk
about us. And then >> and and and what did people say about
Trump supporters? It's worse. >> I believe when we go,
okay, you bet. These are the new rules. Fine. We'll play by those
rules, too. No, no. This was happening ever since the very beginning.
This has always been what's happened. And I think the reason
why people like Kyle were upset is that the words that they have
used for many, many years, things like racist, etc., all these
words have effectively lost all their meaning. Like nobody really
cares whenever they hear these words anymore because you've used
them so much that there's been a diminishing return on it that
people hear the word and they just immediately stop paying attention
to you. And the reason why is because you've overused it. You've
used it for everything. And so I think the problem really why
Kyle's upset about it is
hold on. Kyle just tweeted brand new Kyle Kiski tweet right here.
Trump illegally bombs Yemen, Somalia, Iran. Plots regime change
in Venezuela. Attacks 22 fishing boats killing 83 people. Threatens
Greenland, Panama, and Mexico. Says he wants to reinvade of Afghanistan
all while building concentration camps and ending due process.
As at Asmin Gold, the left are violent terrorists.
Hey, that's a funny picture though. Asmin Gold. The thing is
is you're just powering up Asmin Gold's judo. Okay, he's about
to set this as his like Twitter background. Okay, he's about
to make this his Twitter banner profile or his Twitter profile
banner. All right, you got to be careful cuz Azold embraces all
these bad things about himself, right? You got to be careful.
Got to watch it. Got to watch it. My favorite part of this is
if you don't look at the studies and the objective data, I'm
right and Kyle is wrong. add Democratic derangement syndrome
to his other well-known ailment of showered derangement syndrome.
Okay. Okay. That >> Oh, is this about USAD?
>> It's very obvious that political violence have been
the massively
>> And if you look at all these studies, by the way, that
were conducted, >> these studies don't show a massive rise
in violence that happened
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. Haha. He's a
>> They don't show the massive rises in violence that happened
during the Tesla bombings, for example. And the reason why is
because all these >> Oh, I get it.
>> he's uh you're you're joking about this guy. He's he's
on the the I don't know what to call it. It's not the Iron Throne.
We'll come up with a different We'll come up with a better name.
Okay.
[__] Kyle's going to lose this drama.
Ah,
he might. Ast's difficult to fight with. Okay.
Asmin Gold is hard to fight with. I don't know how you win this
in the public, especially because Asmin Gold, listen, Originally
started as some kind of like destiny adjacent thing, right? It
was that's that's how he started. But eventually, he turned into
like 100% he is like Asmin Gold driven now more than anything.
Okay. It's like Asmin Gold fans in the replies all the time.
And I think Kyle doesn't understand there's like a whole network
behind this guy. All right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's it's it's
he's an Asminold account now. Asmin. Well, he's primarily anti-Hassan.
Yes. No. No. No. He Let's be real. He's primarily anti-Hassan,
but it's like it's his big fans, all of his followers, they're
as gold people. Asmin Gold sent all of his there. It's kind of
funny
I feel like Destiny and Dan spent a lot of time getting this
guy spun up and he probably does like, you know, he probably
feels like they helped him a lot, but now I feel like Asminold
just kept retweeting him, kept responding to all of this and
now now it's just all Asminold followers in the replies like
all the time. It's very very funny. Asminold sort of took the
investment they put into it and he totally co-opted it. I don't
know if he I don't know if he meant to do that, but Asminold
like got all of his followers on this account. Like everybody
follows this account and Asminold replies to all of his and quotes
all of his [__] Asminold like judoed this stuff in
in such a funny way. And I can't tell if it's smart or if it's
intuition or if he just got lucky, but I mean there's only so
many times somebody gets lucky before you start going, "Okay,
maybe they've got a formula. He's as much of a Destiny clipper
as he's an Asin Clipper." Well, I think he's a Destiny fan. I'm
saying that Asminold
like took this account and started retweeting and quote tweeting
all of his and that's like made it so a ton of the people who
would follow him follow this account. So he's like co-opted it
in a way. It's not even really about Ox intention. It's about
how other people interact with the account, right? It's like
if you constantly had Trump re like quote tweeting you as a news
source, suddenly there'd be a bunch of MAGA people who followed
you as a new source, right? Be like a totally different setup
for you. >> They're also including right-wing violence
in prisons. Yeah. And and again, the these studies are
they are biased. They're biased and they are okay. Anyway,
these studies are all biased. I don't trust any of the studies,
guys. I'm going to reference the studies and tell you why they're
bad and why they're biased and why you shouldn't pay attention
to them at all.
Don't don't trust the science, okay? Oh boy. Is that the optics
game that Democrats, I think, and a lot of these liberal people
had a monopoly over, especially in media, has now, I think, to
some degree, been evened. And you have obviously Republicans
saying crazy [__] about Democrats and Democrats have
repeatedly said crazy [__] about Republicans. But
for the early 2010s and I think also for the 2020s as well, uh
there has been a tremendous amount of optics that have been defined
and controlled primarily by Democrats. And it's Democrats labeling
somebody as something and then that person having to defend themselves
from that label. This has been the primary operating mechanism
that they have used to control discourse for a very long time.
And now that it's not working anymore, people like Kyle are crying
and now they're saying, "Okay, now it's time to take the gloves
off." You never had them on. You never had them on to begin with.
This is always what's happened. how you whine and cry and bimone.
No, get the [__] out of here. Get the [__]
compare what Obama has called Republicans or what Biden has called
Republicans to what Trump has called Democrats. It is night and
day. >> Those are the only three people that are involved
by the way. That's it. Those are the only three people. >> You
get, you know, buttoned up civility professional presidents from
Biden and Obama when it comes to their language. >> I don't
know about I don't know about being buckled up in civility with
with Biden. I think he was basically a a walking corpse. But
I would agree with him like with Obama. I think Obama was great
in terms of like how he carried himself and how he acted as president.
I think he was great. Yeah. I think it was way better than Trump
and also way better than Biden in terms of like being an international
representative of the country. For sure. Yeah. True.
>> The other side. But Trump, no. He's throwing haymakers
left and right. And like I said, finally the Democrat, >> this
is after they tried to put him in jail and you know, like they
gave him mugsh shot, charged him 34 times for the same exact
crime. Uh I mean 34 felonies. I mean, come on. What are we doing
here? Uh it's pretty obvious that this has been weaponized from
both directions. >> That is okay. Yeah. [__]
Jay Jones, fine. We're totally fine with him. And >> Exactly.
And so now, finally, finally, now we have the act. By the way,
does he put any orange stuff on that Trump has? Look at his eyes.
And look at his
What's going on here? How does this happen? Uh yeah, I don't
know. I I just think it's odd, right? Oh no, he's coming for
the guy fury aesthetic. Kyle, don't let this guy live. You got
to you got to kill him now, Kyle. You got you got to get him
now. And uh yeah. Anyway, so perspective. Yeah. And so um let
me let me go. So okay, so so now now you're in favor and you're
okay with Jay Jones. Okay, that's fine. And now we have an actual
conversation because before he was saying, "Oh, this isn't happening.
It's not going to happen, etc." But no, actually it is happening.
You know it's happening and you're okay with it. So that's fine.
Want to cry? Now you want to now you want more. Well maybe you
should have [__] thought that when Trump was calling
us the enemy within and [__] terrorists. Maybe you
because before that nobody ever said anything bad about Trump
or anything bad about his supporters ever. You see he started
it. Uh-huh. Sure. Police your own side a little more. We wouldn't
have gotten to the point where Jay Jones would be the standard
bear >> if you're going to vote for that person. >> That's
right. And also like and I think this is another thing that's
very revealing and it's also revealing in a way that I think
Democrats justify violence and rationalize it is that they use
things like calling somebody an idiot or calling somebody a lunatic
or whatever or an enemy and then they compare that with somebody
else fantasizing about literally someone and I think this is
more of the words or violence I think uh what would you really
call it a grift uh the manipulation basically that word like
your words are violence and my violence is freedom of speech.
That's basically it. There's no comparison. Yeah, it's not even
remotely close. And you're not supposed justifying wanting to
kill children. I don't know why you would do that. I don't know
why. Well, he said it wasn't even what happened. Even though
Jay Jones said that's literally what he said. You just see the
the the [__] text message. It's right there. Also,
if you act like a terrorist, maybe you are a terrorist. Yeah.
And exactly. And also, by the way, I'm going to I'm going to
be honest. If you are the kind of Why did he just say, "Yeah,
the person that's going out and you are burning down Teslas,
you are destroying property, you are vandalizing things, you're
victimizing people, you're blocking roads, and you're destroying
things. You are the How is burning the Whimos like the number
one thing Asmin Gold talks about? How? Like, shouldn't she just
have a better example than burning the Whimos?
Now I know why Queen was so upset about me talking about those
Whimos for like two seconds. Now, now I know, now I know why
he was so mad about it. He must have lost his mind about Asminagold
talking about it. I couldn't figure out why he was so upset about
like I was like, "Oh yeah, it's kind of bad to burn." He's like, "I
heard you were soing about the Whimos." No.
seems kind of bad though. I just wouldn't lead with it as like
a reason for thinking the left's violent. I I'm sure there are
a bunch of other reasons
>> the enemy within. You absolutely aren't. This is something
that is objective. It's not about the Democrat or Republican.
You are the enemy within. You are a lunatic. You are crazy and
you need to be put in jail. And that's why we have laws against
these things but with rather nominations from them. Well, then
I I don't want to hear from you about how bad it is that somebody
said something bad in the group chat. >> Yeah, it it's
just absolutely incredible. It's amazing how he can flip the
reality on its head. >> Well, you've got to at least get
the reality right, huh? so smoothly, you know, and not not even
think twice about it. Not even think twice about it. Meanwhile,
who's the biggest commentator on the right these days? Nick Fentes.
Here's some stuff Nick Fuentes has said. Quote, was really cool.
I admire uh I don't care that much about about the genocide in
in Gaza. I'm he like he's pro Palestine. That's what he's actually
said about it. Um he said women shouldn't have the right to vote.
Boys and girls should get married and how many crazy leftist
people are out there. Oh, but Hassan said this thing. What the
does that have to do with me? >> Oh, but but Nick said
this thing. Okay.
All right. his teens. Quote, "Be against women's rights. Be against
them getting educated." He said, "Ban birth controls, ban birth
control, ban contraceptives. Uh, don't allow women in the workplace.
Ban them from voting. Pornography should be banned." >> I
don't know why I don't know why I said all this. I don't remember
saying any of this myself at all. >> He called for Catholic
Taliban rule. He said, quote, "Okay, it's starting to get gay.
Starting to get gay." Now that he's quoting Nick, it's starting
to get gay. I do. So, man, we've got a couple different things
to cover. I do kind of want to get into Venezuela at some point,
too. But I want to move forward because if we cover the MTG stuff,
we can move on. We can move. We can do the MTG stuff. Apparently,
there's a little pisco thing on the Fuentes Tucker stuff. People
thought I should take a look at that. We might take a look at
that. And then after that, we can move on to the Alex Neville
Destiny piece. I'm going to check that out as well. Okay.
we get I'll give this like two more minutes and then we're going
to move on to Marjorie Taylor Green and the the Trump schism
there. Okay. >> We want to go back to the Middle Ages.
This is this is your side and this is the future of your [__]
side. He >> "Okay, I mean like I
what I mean what does that have to do >> democracy is wrong?
Quote, I hate the poor. I love the rich and you're gonna come
after us. You're going to come after us. The left who the core
of what we believe is, hey, everybody should be treated equally
and fairly."
>> Okay? Except for people that you're running against.
>> The core of what we believe is we should have universal
healthcare and free >> Then why were you okay with the
ACA? that was just basically a uh welfare for these companies
>> and a living wage and we should end the wars and we
should let people join unions. We should have paid time off by
law, paid vacation time, paid maternity >> This is I think
the problem is that with a lot of these things I actually agree
with him on. Now we might agree, we might disagree with like
how to get there, but like I also want a lot of these things
too, but I think that these fixation around identity politics
and these fringe extreme topics like Jay Jones wanting >> Okay,
also I don't care. But we're back. We're back. We're alive on
Twitch again, guys. It's back. Okay, we'll never get banned again.
We'll never ever ever get banned again. We're safe. We're We're
I I feel like I'm going to save this video so we can keep watching
it at some point in a little bit.